at least I've discovered what it is we
put our speakers through sweaty palms
sleepless nights a wholly unnatural fear
of clocks I mean it's it's quite brutal
and I'm also a little nervous about this
there are 9 billion humans coming our
way now the most optimistic dreams can
get dented by the prospect of people
plundering the planet but recently I've
become intrigued by a different way of
thinking of large human crowds because
there are circumstances where they can
do something really cool it's a
phenomenon that I think any organization
or individual can tap into it's
certainly impacted the way we think
about Ted's future and perhaps the
world's future overall so let's explore
the story starts with just a single
person a child behaving a little
strangely this kids known online as
little demon he's doing tricks here
dance tricks that probably no
six-year-old in history never managed
before how did he learn them and what
drove him to spend the hundreds of hours
of practice this must have taken so that
was sent me by this man a filmmaker
Jonathan choo who told me that was the
moment he realized the Internet was
causing dance to evolve this is what he
said at Ted in February I mean in
essence dancers were challenging each
other online to get better incredible
new dance skills were being invented
even the six-year-olds were joining in
and it felt like a revolution and so
John had a brilliant idea he went out to
recruit the best of the best dancers off
of YouTube to create this dance troupe
the league of extraordinary dancers the
lxd I mean these kids were web taught
but they were so good they got to play
the Oscars this year and at Ted here in
February that passion and brilliance
just took our breath away
so this story of the evolution of dance
seems strangely familiar you know a
while after TED talks started taking off
we noticed that speakers were starting
to spend a lot more time in preparation
it was resulting an incredible new talk
like these two months of preparation
crammed into 18 minutes raising the bar
cruelly for the next generation of
speakers with the effects that we've
seen this week and it's not as if JJ and
Jill actually ended their talk saying
step your game up
but they might as well have so in both
of these cases you've got these cycles
of improvement apparently driven by
people watching web video what is going
on here well I think it's the latest
iteration of the phenomenon we can call
crowd accelerated innovation and there
are just three things you need for this
thing to kick into gear you could think
of them as three dials and a giant wheel
you turn up the dials the wheel starts
to turn and the first thing you need is
a crowd a group of people who share a
common interest the bigger the crowd the
more potential innovators there are
that's important but actually most
people in the crowd occupied these other
roles they're creating the ecosystem
from which innovation emerges the second
thing you need is light you need clear
open visibility of what the best people
in that crowd are capable of because
that is how you will learn how you will
be empowered to participate and third
you need desire you know
innovations hard work it's based on
hundreds of hours of research of
practice absent desire not going to
happen now here's an example
pre-internet of this machine in action
dancers at a street corner you know it's
a crowd a small one but they can all
obviously see what each other can do and
the desire part comes I guess from
social status right
best answer walk store gets the best aid
there's probably going to be some
innovation happening here but on the web
all three dials are ratcheted right up
the dance community is now global
there's millions connected and amazingly
you can still see what the best can do
because the crowd itself shines a light
on them either directly through comments
ratings email Facebook Twitter you know
or indirectly through numbers of views
through links that point Google there so
it's easy to find the good stuff when
you found it you can watch it in
close-up repeatedly and read what
hundreds of people have written about it
that's a lot of life but the desire
element is really you know dialed way up
I mean you might just be a kid with a
webcam but if you can do something that
goes viral you get to be seen by the
equivalent of sports stadiums crammed
with people you get hundreds of
strangers writing exactly about you and
even if it's not that eloquent and it's
not it can still really make your day so
this possibility of a new type of global
recognition I think it's driving huge
amounts of effort and it's important to
note that it's not just the stars who
are benefiting because you can see the
best everyone can learn also the system
is self fueling you know it's the crowd
that shines the light and fuels the
desire but the Lightning desire are a
lethal one-two combination that attract
new people to the crowd so this is a
model pretty much any organization could
use to try and nurture its own cycle of
crowd accelerated innovation invite the
crowd letting the light dial up the
desire and the hardest part about that
is probably the light because it means
you have to open up now you have to show
your stuff to the world it's by giving
away what you think is your deepest
secret that maybe millions of people are
empowered to help improve it and very
happily there's one class of people who
really can't make use of this tool you
know the dark side of the way
is allergic to the light I don't think
we're gonna see terrorists for example
publishing their plans online and same
to the world please could you help us to
actually make them work this time but
you can publish your stuff online and if
you can get that wheel to turn you know
look out
so at EDD we've become a little obsessed
with this idea of openness that my
colleague Jim Kahn's taken to calling it
radical openness because it works for us
each time we opened up our talks to the
world and suddenly there are millions of
people out there helping spread our
speaker's ideas and thereby making it
easier for us to recruit and motivate
the next generation of speakers by
opening up our translation program
thousands of heroic volunteers some of
them watching online right now and thank
you have translated our talks into more
than 70 languages thereby tripling our
viewership in non-english speaking
countries by giving away our TEDx brand
we suddenly have a thousand plus live
experiments in the art of spreading
ideas and these organizers they're
seeing each other they're learning from
each other we are learning from them
we're getting great talks back from them
the wheel is turning okay step back a
minute I mean it's really not news for
me to tell you that innovation emerges
out of groups you know we've heard that
this week this romantic notion of the
lone genius with a Eureka moment that
changes the world is misleading even he
said that and he wouldn't know where our
social species we spark off each other
it's also not news to say that the
Internet has accelerated innovation you
know for the past 15 years powerful
communities have been connecting online
sparking off each other if you take
programmers you know the whole
open-source movement is a fantastic
instance of crowd accelerator innovation
but what's key here is that the reason
these groups have been able to connect
is because their work output is of the
type that can be easily shared digitally
a picture music file software
and that's why you know what I'm excited
about or what I think is underreported
is the significance of the rise of
online video this is the technology
that's going to allow the rest of the
world's talents to be shared digitally
thereby launching a whole new cycle of
crowd accelerated innovation the first
few years of the web we're pretty much
video free for this reason video files
are huge the web couldn't handle them
but in the last 10 years bandwidth has
exploded a hundredfold suddenly here we
are
humanity watches 80 million hours of
YouTube every day Cisco actually
estimates that within 4 years more than
90 percent of the web's data will be
video if it's all puppies porn and
piracy we're doomed
I don't think it will be video is high
bandwidth for a reason it packs a huge
amount of data and our brains are
uniquely wired to decode it here let me
introduce you to Sam Hebert
he's a unicyclist before YouTube there
was no way for him to discover his
sports true potential because he can't
communicate this stuff in words right
but looking at video clips posted by
strangers a world of possibility opens
up for him suddenly he starts to emulate
and then to innovate and a global
community of unicyclists discover each
other online inspire each other to
greatness and there are thousands of
other examples of this happening of
video driven evolution of skills ranging
from the you know the physical to the
artful and I have to tell you as a
former publisher of hobbyist magazines I
find this strangely beautiful I mean
there's a lot of passion right here on
the screen but if Rube Goldberg machines
and video poetry aren't quite your cup
of tea
how about this job is a website that was
founded to encourage scientists to
publish their peer-reviewed research on
video there's a problem with the
traditional scientific paper it could
take months for a scientist in another
lab to figure out how to replicate the
experiments that are described in print
here's one such frustrated scientist
mosh pits further the under of Jove he
told me that the world's wasting
billions of dollars on this but look at
this video I mean know if you can show
us instead of just describing that
problem goes away so it's not
far-fetched to say that at some point
online video is when a dramatically
accelerate scientific advance here's
another example that's close to our
hearts our Ted where video is sometimes
more powerful than print the sharing of
an idea why do people like watching TED
Talks
all those ideas already out there in
print it's actually faster to read them
to view why would someone bother well we
see there's some showing as well as
telling but even leaving the screen out
of it there's still a lot more being
transferred than just words and it's in
that non verbal portion there's some
serious magic somewhere hidden in the
physical gestures the vocal cadence the
facial expressions that eye contact
the passion kind of awkward British body
language the you know the sense of how
the audience are reacting that there are
hundreds of subconscious clues that go
to how well you will understand and
whether you are inspired light if you
like and desire and credibly all of this
can be communicated on just a few square
inches of a screen reading and writing
are actually relatively recent
inventions face-to-face communication
has been fine-tuned by millions of years
of evolution that's what's made it into
this mysterious powerful thing it is
someone speaks there's resonance in all
these receding brains the whole group
acts together I mean this is the
connective tissue of the humans super
organism in action it's probably driven
our culture for millennia five hundred
years ago it ran into a competitor with
a lethal advantage it's right here print
scaled the world's ambitious innovators
and influencers now could get their
ideas to spread far and wide and so you
know the art of the spoken word pretty
much withered on the vine
but now in the blink of an eye the game
has changed again it's not too much to
say that what Gutenberg did for writing
online video can now do for face-to-face
communication so that primal medium
which your brain is exquisitely yi4 that
just went global now this is big we we
may have to reinvent an ancient art form
I mean today one person speaking can be
seen by millions shedding bright light
on potent ideas creating intense desire
for learning and to respond and in his
case intense desire to laugh for the
first time in human history talented
students don't have to have their
potential in their dreams written out of
history by lousy teachers they can sit
two feet in front of the world's finest
now Ted is just a small part of this I
mean the world's universities are
opening up their curricula thousands of
individuals and organizations are
showing their knowledge and data online
thousands of people are figuring out new
ways to learn and crucially to respond
completing the cycle and so as we've
thought about this you know it's become
clear to us what the next stage of Ted's
evolution has to be TED Talks can't be a
one-way process one too many our future
is many too many so we're dreaming of
ways to make it easier for you the
global tech community to respond to
speakers to contribute your own ideas
maybe even your own TED Talks and to
help shine a light on the very best of
what's out there because if we can
bubble up the very best from a vastly
larger pool this wheel turns now is it
possible to imagine a similar process to
this happening to global education
overall I mean does it have to be this
painful top-down process why not a self
fueling cycle in which we all can
participate
it's the participation age right schools
can't be silos
can't stop learning age 21 what if in
the coming proud of 9 billion what if
that crowd could learn enough to be net
contributors instead of net plunderers
that changes everything right I mean
that would take more teachers than we've
ever had but the good news is they are
out there they're in the crowd and the
crowd is switching on lights and we can
see them for the first time not was an
undifferentiated mass of strangers but
as individuals we can learn from who's
the teacher you're the teacher you're
part of the crowd that may be about to
launch the biggest learning cycle in
human history a cycle capable of
carrying all of us to a smarter wiser
more beautiful place here's a group of
kids in a village in Pakistan near where
I grew up well in five years each of
these kids is gonna have access to a
cell phone capable a full-on web video
and capable of uploading video to the
web and is it crazy to think that this
girl on the back of the right in 15
years might be sharing the idea that
keeps the world beautiful for your
grandchildren it's not crazy it's
actually happening right now want to
introduce you to a good friend of Ted
who just happens to live in Africa's
biggest shanty town hi my name is
Christopher Macau I'm one of the
organizers of today's Kabira there are
so many good things which are happening
right I am Kira there is a self-help
group they are turn our trash placed
into a garden the same sport it was a
crime sport where people were being
robbed they used the same trash to form
Green Manuel the central site is feeding
more than 30 families we have our own
Film School they are using flip cameras
to record edit and reporting to their
own Channel Kabira
TV the code of scarcity of land we are
using the sack to grow vegetables and
also able to save on the course
of living changes happens when we see
things differently
today I see Camila in a different way my
message to Ted global and the entire
world is kuvira is a hotbed of
innovation and ideas you know what I
thought Chris has always been an
inspiring guy what's new and it's huge
is that for the first time we get to see
him and he can see us right now Chris
and Kevin and Dennis and Dixon and their
friends are watching us in Nairobi right
now guys we've learned from you today
thank you and thank you